Caitlyn Jenner poses with her first  Jenner grandson yes the 66 year old  Jenner has Mason Disick little rain and  Saint West but she has now welcomed the  first gender boy as she put it  Caitlyn's son Bert Jenner is now dad to  baby  Bodhi Jenner and here's Caitlyn posing  with the little guy she instagrammed  quote so excited the first Jenner boys  the name moves on Bodhi was born to Burt  and his girlfriend Valerie  bodis middle name is Burton just like  his dad's name this is Caitlyn's ninth  grandchild things are going well it's  been a big a couple of weeks for Caitlyn  she also just posed for Sports  Illustrated wearing her gold medal about  40 years after winning it  congratulations to the happy thing